Joe and Jackie are with us hey guys how
are you good
welcome welcome good to have you were
you all from Montana Wow what parts of
Montana Colstrip Easton okay very cool
near Billings then yep
all right good well good to have you
guys welcome welcome and you're here to
do your debt-free scream how much have
you paid off seventy thousand nine
hundred ninety nine dollars and forty
six cents
very cool during how how long did it
take you to do that eighteen months Wow
making what kind of money at that time
115 okay what do you guys do for a
living
I'm no electrician at a power plant
mm-hmm and I was a receptionist at a
fitness center mm-hmm and since we
become Dave debt-free I've been able to
step away from that and stay home with
my son oh very cool good and so what
kind of debt was the seventy one
thousand everything a bunch of signature
loans at the credit union we have two
older sons 22 and 20 now and I thought
it'd be best for us just go ahead and
cosign them some loans so they can get
rolling we went ahead and took over all
that when they graduated so they
wouldn't go into the world debt a lot a
bit and that was some of it the rest it
was a car just all we never really were
lucky to have credit cards because we
had such bad credit but we had
everything else we but sites credit
cards student loan it was just all kinds
of signature loans gotcha okay and so
what happened eighteen months ago that
tell me you're that launched you on this
journey tell us tell us what happened um
well actually I'm gonna take you back
about five years ago mm-hmm I was given
the book your total money makeover and I
read it and I wanted to start your
program Joe was not on board so I tried
to do it myself and that doesn't work so
then we had a child in 2013 and during
pregnancy we knew there was some
complications and some friends of ours
had invited us over for dinner
and gave us a substantial gift because
they said you're gonna need this when
she's born and we thought wow this is
awesome and they ended up also given us
a gift and then we had our daughter and
had complications and she lived for 65
days and our friends were right we
needed that money because we were flown
to Denver at Children's and had no money
so that helped us and then Joe was about
ready to buy a brand new truck after we
got home sixty thousand dollars and I
was very uneasy about it and those same
friends told Joe that he was messing up
and not to do that and I said you know
the gift that we gave you was because of
Dave Ramsey and so Matt McBride which
Matt and Bethany are watching sponsors
and they're watching they turned Joe
onto it and have been our mentors ever
since Wow and so that that when your
baby passed that was about 18 months ago
then or about two years ago yeah okay
2013 so kind of when you get up off the
floor from that because that just knocks
you breath out of you for forever in a
real way but if certainly for the first
little while right after that I guess
and then you guys get in you get into
attack mode and go okay we're gonna
change this whole thing now yep Wow so
Joe what flip the switch for you when
you got a buddy that tells you you're
fixing the screw-ups and he literally
did that when I showing him the truck
that I was gonna buy us building it just
waiting for them to come out to market
and why did you trust him he's been
there and done it he was a lot younger
than me and they did it they had success
and he'd already proven he cared about
you with the gift kind of earned the
right to speak into your life didn't he
right that's a good friend we work
together we go to church together we eat
together we our families just meshed you
don't have many good friends like that
in his life
that's good that's a good man it's
awesome guy very
cool and wow what a great result they
were able to bless you because they had
gotten out of debt they lived like no
one else now they're able to give like
no one else and then the you go through
this horrible tragedy and then off the
back of that the blessings start coming
on the financial side Wow we were
blessed with the boy here and yeah and
how old is he 17 months oh wow okay
very cool okay so right on the heels in
yeah excellent
Wow excellent how does it feel to I'm
debt free I'm kind of still in shock you
oughta be in shock too Joe knows this
number to the penny yeah I mean he said
he's all in oh yeah I mean Josie they're
all in or not all in he's nowhere in the
middle with Joe I'm right am i right
jacket yeah yeah I could tell I'm kind
of the same way that's what I could tell
all right very cool you guys will
congratulations so what's your advice
Joe to some guy out there whose wife's
trying to get him to look at this stuff
and you know talk to him about how this
flipped the switch inside of you you
married her for a reason and obviously
it's because you loved him so he's her
warning when she says hey we need to do
this four or five years ago when this
all came up I should have just said yeah
let's let's do it we would have been a
whole different boat things would have
been a lot different but what I got to
say is listen to your bride hmm work
together you're the man I love it
that's beautiful well done so Jackie one
of the secrets to getting out of debt
you guys paid off seventy one thousand
dollars and eighteen months what's the
secrets budget stick to your budget and
that's super hard for me
we had some budget fights but it only
took us like three months to really get
a good budget and a good flow and so for
me it's sticking to the budget I love it
I love it well congratulations you guys
very proud of you sorry for the tragedy
that you've been through but you've got
blessings all around you in the midst of
it God is good and he is all the time
Wow all right Joe and Jackie from the
Billings Montana area 71 thousand
dollars paid off at 18 months making a
hundred and fifty a year count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
Wow